Okay.
We now have to talk about CNNs role in this
second Democratic primary debate.
There is no other way to say it.
CNNs production and management of the presidential
debate over the last two nights was disgusting.
There's no other way to say it.
It was everything that is wrong with political
discourse and with corporate media.
I mean it just, they could have done nothing
worse that I can imagine other than cartoonishly
terrible things that would never really happen
and I'm really talking about everything.
The format was a disaster.
There are handling of the digital rights of
the content itself was an absolute embarrassment.
This really was one of the worst produced
debates from start to finish that I can remember.
And if this is a signal about what to expect
from now until the last debate of 2020 democracy
and discourse is in serious trouble, which
you probably already knew and it's hard to
know even where to start.
I told you yesterday and again in today's
debate wrap up that they tried desperately
to create fake drama, not even hiding the
totally base and brazen ways in which they
were just trying to get candidates to call
each other out.
And first of all, much like with the NBC debate
format, that's really the only way that you
can sort of do well as I've talked about,
when you have a format which allows for very
short answers, even shorter and sporadic rebuttals,
sometimes the shortest 15 seconds, all you
can do is try to bring these kill shot gotcha
moments that is by design and the format reinforces
that and the moderators regularly trying to
pit the candidates against each other.
Not in a way that really helps us explore
issues and ideas.
Listen to me talk about ideas, uh, but only
in a way that encourages these attempts at
kill shots.
Additionally, the debates were way too long.
The first one ran about two hours and 40 minutes.
I think the second night was about two hours
and 45 but understand that our night one,
the first question wasn't asked until 23 minutes
had already gone by.
They started with these sports team introduction,
like videos.
They included a commercial before you even
had the first questions.
They did introductions very slowly, bringing
the candidates out onto the stage.
They did opening statements which tell us
nothing.
And then on the second night, 27 minutes went
by before the first question was even asked,
the opening statements should be done away
with the sports.
Suffocation of the debates should be stopped
and it's just way too long with such little
substance.
The second night going even longer, and again,
almost a half hour before you saw a question,
it started at eight you could have tuned in
at eight 30 and have missed only part of the
first question.
This is an embarrassment.
The response window's obviously too short,
cutting everyone off sometimes after even
only 15 seconds.
Anyone who's serious about learning about
the positions of the candidates could not
have possibly done it from this debate, and
I know the NBC one wasn't anything to write
home about, but the CNN one was even worse.
The moderators were way too much of a presence,
almost like they just wanted to hear themselves
talk.
There are already too many candidates competing
for air time and we've got the moderators
also in that competition.
And then half the questions were premised
on republican talking points for so-called
liberal media, which CNN is accused of being.
They did a hell of a job of asking the questions
that Republican would have, Republicans would
have wanted, asked in the ways that Republicans
would have asked them.
And then as you know, the digital rights management,
CNN shutdown my stream on night one on youtube,
they shut down many other streams from semi-permanent
news and politics.
Youtubers, they gave us a copyright strike
jeopardizing our entire youtube account.
Commandeering an entire day of my time yesterday.
Ultimately getting that strike repealed by
the way, which is a good thing.
Um, and the DNC shouldn't stand for this.
The DNC is complicit and the DNC should be
demanding that whichever network gets to brand
the debate and produce the debate, they should
be forced to allow it for re-purposing as
if it were the state of the Union address
on Cspan.
I actually disagree with debates for public
office even being held by private organizations,
but if they are, they must be treated like
a public service event.
We're picking the next president or at least
the person who will compete to be the next
president in the general election.
It can't be a sporting event for profit at
the exclusion of everybody else.
It was an absolute and total embarrassment.
The next one is in September, ABC News.
Univision together are running it.
I really hope it's not another disgusting
atrocity like what we saw on CNN the last
few nights, but it probably will.
We will be.
Let me know what changes you think would be
the most
a positive that could be made to the way these
debates have been produced so far.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show